good morning this is Dr Andrew Armstrong
at Duke University I'm going to be
presenting a presentation on H prostate
cancer this morning to you uh with a
particular focus on biomarkers and uh
this lecture will be on H prognostic
predictive and surrogate factors
including biomarkers in men with
castration resistant uh prostate cancer
so the more lethal variant of prostate
cancer I'm an associate professor at the
uh the Duke Cancer Institute in the
department of medicine I'm a medical
oncologist I treat patients with
Advanced prostate cancer I'm also a
clinical researcher with a focus on uh
circulating tumor cell biology
experimental Therapeutics and prostate
cancer and I conduct a number of
clinical trials in the disease so let's
get going uh the outline of this talk
will be uh the current state of
prognostic and predictive factors and
biomarkers in men with castration
resistant disease disease as of uh the
current uh date
2013 uh we're going to talk about
surrogates uh for drug development and
prostate cancer we're going to talk
about the working group two criteria and
some of the changes that we might expect
with the newer criteria emerging and
we're going to uh focus on some future
directions I want to emphasize that for
this labout's presentation uh all
questions are welcome I'm going to hold
questions to the end but please uh when
you're um type in your question uh
please do that in real time so that by
the end we'll have a list of questions
that I can go
through so the clinical states of
prostate cancer in 2008 were really
defined by Howard Sher and and
colleagues and really categorize
prostate cancer is localized PSA
recurrent uh metastatic hormone
sensitive metastatic castration
resistant and the non-metastatic setting
as well lethal prostate cancer really is
is illustrated by the red boxes here uh
in metastatic castration resistant
disease where the death rate from
prostate cancer really outpaces the
death from
comorbidities however in
2013 uh we have a number of newly
approved treatments we have a better
understanding of molecular biology and
clinical prognostic phenotypes in
prostate cancer and so the disease State
model in 2013 uh while very similar to
the prior model now illustrates the
importance of prior therapies IND
dictating the next best therapy for a
patient and so first line therapy second
line therapy third line therapy in 2004
was really you know a goal but now we
actually have this plethora of of
therapies that I'll cover a little bit
the goals moving forward however are to
really model our disease after many of
the other oncologic diseases such as
breast cancer and lung cancer where we
have a molecular taxonomy for
adenocarcinomas and we can use that to
both rest stratify but also to predict
for therapies that may be of benefit
directly to our patients and clinic and
as you can see in this uh Cartoon uh
disease burden really increases over
this disease State uh to more treatment
refractory
settings so the M there are multiple
treatment options for men with prostate
cancer now uh Beyond surgery and
radiation and hormonal standard therapy
that induces castration we have a number
of treatment options available to men
with um metastatic disease that is
failed hormonal therapy so the
definition of castration resistance is
progression in the face of a lowlevel
testosterone typically 50 nanograms per
deciliter and the treatment options for
men with metastatic disease are now
based on whether a patient has symptoms
or not the presence of visceral disease
it includes imuno theapy with
CP aerone enzalutamide is now are both
mov moving and positioning themselves to
be sandwiched around immunotherapy in
the the pre-os taxel setting dos taxel
is largely being used after these
hormonal and
immunotherapies and we now have a number
of Agents approved in the post doot
taxal setting including these same
hormonal therapies kabazi taxel and
radium 223 are most recently approved
Alpha emitter so I'm going to not focus
on these therapies directly but really
on uh understanding the heterogeneity of
the disease biology and how we can use
biomarkers to help select patients for
these therapies one of the problems in
prostate cancer is that castration
resistant disease involves many
mechanisms of progression some of which
involve mechanisms that are independent
of the AR or indirectly involve the AR
and these can be shown broadly here that
involve immunologic Escape oncogenic
proliferative signals that act
independent of the AR survival signals
that involve
tumor suppressor loss bone micro
environment signals you know prostate
cancer commonly spreads to Bone and the
bone Fosters uh survival of these tumors
uh and their growth and resistance to
therapies there's a number of other kind
of um terms called stemness or
epithelial to meenal transition Pathways
as well as DNA repair that are also
important that I lumped in the bottom
there but the Androgen receptor Remains
the number one Target for prostate
cancer and there's a lot of overlap with
these AR independent mechanisms the
mechanisms of AR dependent castration
resistant growth involve AR
amplification overexpression gene
mutations such as activating point
mutations mRNA splice or deletion
variants glucocorticoid receptor
upregulation which can hi hijack the
transcriptome of the AR as well as
emerging data on the ectopic Androgen
production by uh prostates uh
particularly castration resistant
prostate cancer that can really turn
into an endocrine or autocrine organ
manufacturing its own uh endocrine lians
for use by an amplified receptor there
are also a number of AR dependent Fusion
proteins and many of the top purple
signals can overlap and talk to the AR
including the retinol blastoma family
parp um urg Pathways as well as a number
of others I'm not going to spend a lot
of time on molecular biology but
the biomarkers that we might use in the
clinic to really identify patients who
have these diverse mechanisms of
progression the good news in the past
few years is that we have six new drugs
uh showing real clinical benefit kabazi
taxel has improved survival provenge or
sepulus LT immunotherapy has improved
survival in asymptomatic patients uh the
cougar 301 and 302 trials have
positioned abadone is a a drug with real
clinical benefit both in the pre and
postdose taxal settings denosumab has
prevented skeletal related events to a
greater degree than we've had previously
without an improvement in survival
radium 223 has extended survival for the
most symptomatic patients with bone
predominant metastatic disease and then
enzalutamide uh was positive and
reported uh last year in the affirmed
trial in the post doot taxal setting
with the Prevail trial anticipated um in
the next few weeks so we we have major
questions with new agents the
appropriate
sequencing uh over these therapies the
the use of combinations versus single
agent therapies that are facing many
other disease types and then patient
selection uh patient and tumor factors
I.E biomarkers can help us maximize the
benefit to our individual uh patient
with castration resistant disease and
then minimize the harm of unnecessary or
ineffective therapies as well as the
burden of the cost of these uh very
expensive drugs uh that may or may not
work in certain
patients and so drug development and
castration resistant disease there are
many impediments although we've had
success uh there has generally been a
lack of the understanding of clinical
crpc progression of the of the biology
and these biomarkers in the clinic uh
metastatic biopsies are difficult to
obtain and linking these to event
outcomes is really a goal of many
current ongoing research studies these
men are typically older in their 60s and
70s with competing causes of
cardiovascular mortality and other
mortality there's been a lack of many
surrogates for survival uh that the FDA
has accepted for approval and as I just
showed you there's great disease
heterogeneity you know just because we
call one disease prostate cancer doesn't
mean it has the same underlying
molecular biology and we've seen that
from high throughput genomic studies of
metastatic prostate cancer essentially
each each tumor and each patient is is
really uh different genetically and so
the key remaining questions are how do
we make sense of early phase trials to
move them forward how do we use
biomarkers to maximize benefit so let's
start with a few definitions this is a a
broad lecture on biomarkers especially
as they relate to prostate cancer so a
biomarker is defined as a a
characteristic that is objectively
measured and evaluated as an indicator
of normal or abnormal pathogenic
processes or a response to an
intervention and these can include
survey results blood tests genetic
biomarkers urine test radiographic
Imaging is certainly a biomarker a pain
score is a biomarker if it's
quantitative and objectively measured
and so biomarker here is a broad term uh
I'm going to talk mostly about uh
several types of biomarkers but there
are many types of biomarkers these
include prognostic predictive surrogate
pharmacodynamic pharmacokinetic
biomarkers mechanistic type biomarkers
prognostic biomarkers however are a
particular type and these are disease
and host
characteristics uh that estimate the
chance of uh some natural history events
such as death or progression in the
sense of cancer most commonly recurrence
just to give you an example of this on
this slide would be PSA PSA is a
prognostic factor across the disease uh
Continuum from localized disease to
castration resistant disease the higher
the PSA the worse the prognosis in many
cases uh but predictive factors are
really a a different um criteria these
are also disease or host characteristics
but now they estimate the chance of
specific improvements with a particular
treatment in breast cancer for example
her two oncoprotein expression
overexpression really predicts for the
benefit of herto directed therapy uh and
I'm going to talk about uh predictive
factors in prostate cancer next so each
of these factors can be used to grow
group patients for trials or in the
clinic uh into relatively homogeneous
subsets defined by biology or clinical
phenotype and can optimize the delivery
of care depending on the context of use
so here is a table of the validated
prognostic biomarkers in castration
resistant disease and the this listing
is based on existing nomograms and
multivariant models uh not all nomograms
measured the same things at the same
time so we don't have an
all-encompassing nomogram that has
everything in them but these biomarkers
that I display here have been
independently validated multiple data
sets and they include some very obvious
prognostic factors such as pain and the
functional status of a patient uh
certain blood tests such as lactate
dehydrogenase the PSA level in the PSA
kinetics your circulating tumor cell
count in certain settings the degree of
anemia the pattern of spread
particularly visceral disease being a
poor prognostic finding measures of
inflammation such as C reactive protein
and albumin measures of bone turnover
such as alkaline phosphatase and urine
enop peptides even the glein score is an
important one uh others are listed here
as well uh with some controversy and as
well after you start a treatment whether
it's a hormonal treatment or
chemotherapy uh if these biomarkers
change or improve they are also
prognostic so if your PSA goes down you
may live longer pain Improvement quality
of life improvements they're all linked
and associated with better outcome
that doesn't make them predictive unless
they're tied to a specific therapy
because any therapy that improves these
will result in better outcomes
progression free survival changes in
circulating tumor cell enumeration are
also prognostic as our bone turnover
markers for immunologic correlates we
also have uh immune response so elispot
assay have been associated with improved
outcomes and there is a frequent misuse
of the word predictive in the literature
I'm going to highlight on this slide
here a comparison of different
prognostic models so when you're in the
clinic Which prognostic models do you
use uh treating men with metastatic
castration resistant disease these are
some some of the three available
although more are emerging uh really uh
as the trials are updated and published
but these are based on these trials are
based on older uh data the tax 327 study
which I've been a part of um is probably
the most contemporary of these three um
this involved the th6 pat s and was able
to prognosticate up to five years and
had a relatively good predictive ability
that incorporated 10 or 11 different
prognostic factors and was really
validated within a pivotal dose of taxal
uh trial so really uh contemporary use
is is present for the tax 327 nomogram
uh that is to say until we have all
these new treatments and so as our new
treatments kind of push chemotherapy
back a little bit and we have different
set settings where we want to
prognosticate other nomograms and
prognostic models will become important
in different settings and I would just
put in a plug for uh we we have
developed a an iPhone app for the tax
327 nomogram you can find this on the
App Store just was released about two
weeks ago uh and that can help you in
the clinic kind of estimate for a given
patient their prognosis in the pre- doot
taxal setting as well as in another
nomogram that we validated in the postd
doot taxel setting and this is just an
example of our postdose taxl nomogram uh
and this is taken right from the
clinical cancer research paper uh
several years ago showing how we can
take many different factors and put them
together on a single patient and
estimate their six and 12 and 24 months
survival natural history of course this
Natural History can be improved now that
we have more an a active treatments that
can extend that survival but it gives
you a sense for what to tell a patient
in the clinic who may want to to know
whether to pursue further therapy based
on their current prognosis should they
not receive um more
therapies um and this is an example of a
prognostic factor uh PSA doubling time
or the rate of Rise of the PSA is very
important across the disease setting and
castration resistant disease and
localized disease as well as biochemical
recurrent disease and you can see here
going from white to Red uh there's a
very important uh change uh as you can
see and I'm drawing here uh as as your
PSA doubling time lengthens survival
time improves and that is a real
independent validated prognostic factor
which is incorporated into our models so
there's some pros and cons of nomograms
obviously they can be helpful for trial
stratification you know if you want to
ensure balance between two arms they
have pretty good prognostic ability uh
although by the time they get published
they're often out of date um and they
can but they can identify high and low
risk groups of patients they can
facilitate communication in the clinic
uh with uh historic caveats and um but
they have some limitations they often
are based on convenience samples the
trials that use them and measured these
variables often lack other variables uh
they're they give some incorrect
information about 30% of the time so um
they're imperfect and um they do have
some missing data importantly on the the
disease heterogeneity and underlying
oncogenic signatures mutations for
example are not incorporated into these
nomograms and that's the Hope moving
forward here's another example of a a
prognostic factor that is useful both
before and after dose of taxel is the
measurement of circulating tumor cells
and this is a simple blood test much
like a PSA but instead of measuring a a
protein that's made by tumor such as PSA
this is actually measuring the tumor
cells themselves in the bloodstream and
you can imagine that if you have a high
number of circulating tumor cells uh you
have a poor prognosis of around 11
months and men with metastic disease in
the pre- doxel setting who go on to
receive dose taxel and likewise if you
have a a low circulating tumor cell
count less than five you have an
improved prognosis of about a year and a
half to two years but most importantly
these tumor cells can be altered in the
course of effective therapy so going
from the green line to uh the orange
line would indicate progression of a
patient despite dose of taxel in a poor
prognosis and likewise going from the
red line to the blue line can indicate
an improved prognosis in which uh you
can update a patient on their prognosis
as their circulating tumor cells Decline
and provide some reason for optimism
during a course of therapy there's a
number of ways to use prognostic models
you can use nomograms which include you
know 10 or 11 or 12 or even more
variables uh and that's why we developed
an app for
this um or you can be more simplistic
about it and lump the most important
risk factors into what's called a risk
group and we've published on this in
European Journal of cancer uh there's
four major risk factors in ceration
resistance disease at least in our data
set that include the presence of
important pain requiring narcotic
analgesia the presence of liver
particular particularly visceral
metastases the development of new bone
lesions prior to therapy and progress of
anemia and when you take these four risk
factors you can create risk groups much
like the kidney cancer risk groups that
we're all familiar with good risk
castration resistant disease has zero to
one risk factors and you can see here a
survival that's around two years much
like the sislt type patient and who is
asymptomatic and has no visceral disease
and a poor RIS patient has three or four
of these risk factors and this is much
like the Alima trial data that led to
the approval of radium these patients
are poor risk they have pain they have
new bone lesions they have a poor
survival uh this is simply reporting on
natural history and uh these risk groups
can be used for clinical trials they can
also be useful for busy clinicians who
can't remember all the nomogram factors
and can simply estimate just by looking
at a patient with some very easy to
remember clinical risk
factors um I want to show this this is a
paper that we have in press and European
Urology uh illustrating the importance
of visceral metastases in dictating
survival in this castration resistance
setting uh and this shows the pattern of
spread ranging from node only disease
right here with a survival in excess of
two years to patients with uh liver
metastases and uh this group of patients
is some of the the most poor prognostic
patients in which a survival of under a
year is expected and better treatments
are needed so the pattern of spread
really dictates survival in many
patients uh interestingly in this study
the the patients with bone only disease
did uh nearly as well as the patients
with lymph nodee only
disease and patients with lung
metastases did much better uh than
patients with liver metastases showing
that the pattern of visceral spread is
even important here and the importance
of visceral disease is important because
many drugs don't work as well in the
presence of visceral disease however
they still may work uh so here's an
example from a poster at ASCO this past
year showing that
enzalutamide does work in both patients
with lung and liver metastases but the
overall survival of these patients is
much shorter than you might expect as
you can see here only nine months with
enzalutamide treatment in the presence
of liver
metastases while lung metastases
patients did a lot better and there was
a benefit with enamide in this setting
but we really need better therapies that
can address the visceral spread of
cancer so the application of these
prognostic models to patient management
obviously we talked about creating
homogeneous clinical populations uh for
our trials but also to help at the
bedside with
prognostication uh we're trying to
develop more easyto use nomograms such
as these apps that I mentioned uh as
well as more updated models based on
contemporary series of treated
patients let's touch based now on
predictive factors predictive factors
are really uh quite easy to describe in
prostate cancer there are none yet and
um one of the areas of research that I
spend a lot of time thinking about and
many in our field do is trying to
develop predictive biologic factors uh
that can lead to better therapies
specifically for men with these factors
as I mentioned there are many phenotypes
of prostate cancer there are many
genotypes as well and the qualification
requirements with the FDA for a
biomarker are very intense and often uh
just as intense as the phase three trial
of these drugs um as we can see many new
drugs in oncology are getting approved
with companion Diagnostics such as her
two testing or brass testing or egfr
testing for mutations uh and the
consideration for validation analytic
validation clinical validation is is
very intense to make sure you have a
validated test that has been qualified
through external validation through
perspective trials across different
mechanisms uh ideally and just as an
example uh of some predictive biomarkers
that have shown some success in oncology
breast cancer leads the way certainly
with her2 estrogen progesterone receptor
which are clearly linked to better
outcomes with certain drugs lung adnoc
carcinom becoming quite a heterogeneous
disease with egfr defined adenocarcinoma
ALK fusions you know very U much uh
histology dependent um predictive
biomarkers with certain chemotherapy
therapy agents coloral cancer and Ras
mutations and the lack of benefit of
certain drugs hematologic malignancies
have long understood the value of
predictive biomarkers for rmab and GAC
for the Philadelphia chromosome gastric
cancer has recently shown some some data
with her too and renal cell carcinoma a
GU malignancy has had several predictive
factors such as LDH predicting for the
benefit of an mtor inhibitor histology
is a simple predictive fact factor and
for the benefit of cyto
therapy some potential potential
predictive biomarkers and castration
resistant disease these are challenging
but um uh clearly there's a sense that
AR activation or ar mutations May
predict for enzalutamide resistance or
sensitivity there's been a recent study
that Androgen precursor levels actually
are not a predictor for abadone
sensitivity patients with low Androgen
levels still seem to benefit at least in
the serum uh seem to benefit from
abadone so that is not a predictor uh
there's a number of uh drugs targeting
the pi3 Kines pathway and looking for um
pathway activation as a predictor recent
data on microtubular mutations and
measuring these in circulating tumor
cells may be a taxane sensitivity
predictor measures of high alkaline
phosphatase seem to be a predictor for
radium uh but that requires validation
there are some 1% of prostate cancers
have Ras mutations there're ongoing
studies looking at DNA repair Inhibitors
such as par Inhibitors particularly in
the context of these urg fusions that
can cause DNA repair defects uh the
intact retinoblastoma protein May
predict for cell cycle Inhibitors um
another recent one that was just
published a few weeks ago is glein score
so high glein score seem to be
predictive for the benefit with dose
taxal chemotherapy which was interesting
and that was published in European
neurology ology there are a number of
others including the neuroendocrine
histology in which Aurora kinas and and
has been Amplified and aor kyes
Inhibitors are under trials for these uh
rare histologies but emerging and
important histologies uh another simple
predictor could be PSA so low disease
burden may be a predictor for the
benefit of immunotherapy and we've seen
the cores plots of cilos LT showing a
greater impact on survival in men with a
low PSA particularly under 20 so that's
kind of a summary there and the goal is
to take these predictors and validate
them in clinical trials and to move from
a h kind of random drug selection uh
with a random uh patient population uh
that's not enriched to uh a more
enriched um setting where we can exploit
tumor vulnerabilities use synthetic
lethal strategies we can uh reduce
oncogene addiction such as through the
AR um we can reduce lians that are
important in patients who are making
lians or we can block um Androgen
receptor where it's Amplified and so
exploiting the tumor specifically where
the Achilles heel exist in a given tumor
is is the emerging um mantra for
prostate cancer going forward I'm going
to put in a plug here for circulating
tumor cells or circulating plasma DNA
ways uh to predict for uh drug benefit
and mutation
and high throughput sequencing using
blood-based tests essentially liquid
biopsy and in both plasma DNA and
circulating tumor cells have shown
important prognostic roles but more
importantly they offer a window into the
biology of the cancer where we may be
able to get to these predictive factors
instead of sticking needles into bones
and tumors which you can't do uh very
often ctc's allow you a a longitudinal
and minimally invasive assess M of tumor
biology provided they can be measured so
this liquid biopsy what can you see in
the circulating tumor cell and here are
some examples of some emerging data just
from the last few years we've shown that
circulating tumor cells can express both
epithelial here um and meenal um
proteins enn cadherin suggesting uh that
EMT is important in ceration resistant
disease you can see that P10 uh is
important uh its loss can be assessed in
uh circulating tumor cells you can see
the importance of AR amplification in
certain prostate cancer patients and so
uh and then down here at the bottom you
can do whole genome approaches in
circulating tumor shell cells
illustrating that you know things like
Androgen receptor can be ascertained
just through the blood um with high
throughput techniques including
mutational analysis so this is really
one opportunity to get it tumor biology
in a non-invasive way there are
limitations the current assay often uh
doesn't lead to circulating tumor cells
being detectable even in the presence of
metastatic disease and about uh a third
to 40% of men it's very dependent on a
single biomarker epcam for the capture
of these cells uh often circulating
tumor cells at least using the current
method is is not uh optimally detecting
cells until patients are really
treatment refractory and in the post a
taxal setting uh we found that epcam
loss is correlated with EMT and the
expression of these stemness markers and
we're actively working and the field is
actively working on developing Next
Generation circulating tumor cell
platforms that may be able to get a
range of CTC phenotypes and different
types of ctc's that are circulating in
the blood of these
patients so on the last few minutes I
want to uh spend some time talking about
surrogate biomarkers this is an
important important area for drug
development for those of you who do
research in prostate cancer um having a
surrogate biomarker is an important step
in in ensuring your drug success so for
those of you in industry and Academia uh
surrogate biomarkers have really been a
way to accelerate drug development and
getting your agent to patients who will
benefit
earlier uh statistically surrogate
biomarkers are defined uh by several
criteria one is by Ross apprentice and
there's the reference in 1989 now uh in
which treatment has to change an
endpoint so it has to improve your
definitive endpoint such as survival say
you have a clinical trial that improves
survival and now you have a surrogate
that you want to test which is an
intermediate variable such as PSA change
or progression free survival the full
effect of the treatment on survival
needs to be explained through the effect
of treatment on the surrogate and you
can quantify this by number of methods
such as the pte statistical method or
likelihood ratio you need to look at
this across many different trials
ideally across different mechanisms and
you can see here simplistically that
treatment needs to alter um the
surrogate and the surrogate needs to be
highly associated with survival but as
we know there are many ways around this
Association that a surrogate might be
associated with survival but the
treatment doesn't change that surrogate
or the treatment may actually reduce
survival independent of the surrogate
through drug toxicity for example so uh
evaluating the association of treatment
with survival is very important and can
be done statistically across many
studies and within
studies so again a simple a simplistic
disc discussion of surrogate biomarkers
and castration resistant disease is that
none to date are definitive across all
trials overall survival Remains the gold
standard for FDA approval and to
determine whether a drug is
beneficial um in a clinical phase three
trial that doesn't mean that other
surrogates you know surrogates are
useless that means that we just haven't
proven them yet uh surrogate biomarkers
do depend on the mechanism of action of
the drug and I'll spend a few minutes on
that with the next few slides some of
the surrogates that are have been
evaluated and are under evaluation right
now include very simple things such as
the PSA going down and the degree of PSA
decline having a pain response or a
radiographic response delaying the time
a patient has before their tumor
progresses uh having uh drop in your
circulating tumor cell count or time to
circulating tumor cell progression Are
all biomarkers uh that are under
evaluation of surrogate end points and
the CTC data and the PFS data are really
the farthest along in their potential to
be surrogates um however you you can get
a drug approved by the FDA
uh by showing clinical benefit without
having to worry about survival or
surrogates the FDA has approved for
example Mido anone based on durable pain
pation there are drugs that we use
commonly zoledronic acid denosumab that
can prevent skeletal related events that
are felt to be clinically relevant and
there are trials ongoing right now such
as with cabozantinib that are evaluating
durable pain pation as a real clinically
meaningful endpoint of course uh we need
to do the studies to really prove that
these endpoints can be can lead to
improved survival but they may be end
points in them for
themselves let's talk about progression
free survival so progression free
survival is variably defined in prostate
cancer uh some progression free survival
uses PSA some doesn't some uses just
radiographic or clinical progression um
you can see here from the curves uh from
Susan halby's work that a patient who is
progression free at three months uh has
a better uh survival long term of 20
months versus a patient who's already
progressed three months into treatment
as a worst survival of about seven
months and the hazard ratio is highly
significant and prostate cancer patients
with castration resistant disease
typically develop PSA progression before
they develop bone progression and before
they develop pain progression and
however there are some disconnections
between those in some
cases however there are many diseases
where the PSA uh progression does not
associate very well with survival and
largely PSA has been dropped from the
criteria in clinical trials for
determining whether a patient's
benefiting from a drug for example we we
clearly know that abadone and
enzalutamide do drop your PSA but that
the pssa can drift upwards during the
course of therapy for many many months
uh before radiographic or clinical
progression
occurs um we also understand that there
are issues with PSA declines and
chemotherapy so such that many cytotoxic
agents can benefit a patient even in the
absence of a robust PSA drop and that
the overall survival improvements can be
seen even with lesser degrees of PSA
decline so let's talk this is a
complicated slide but I want to spend a
few minutes on this this is a graph of
progression free survival Hazard ratios
on the x-axis and overall survival
Hazzard r I on the y axis for all of our
phase three trials and including some
randomized phase two trials as well to
illustrate the value of surrogacy and
progression free survival so in the blue
area that I've colorcoded these are
drugs that are approved or emerging that
have really been had positive studies in
which you can see for example uh kabazi
taxel abadone all showing improvements
in both progression free survival and
overall survival however there's some
real differ es here you see suula LT out
here prostvac right here where there
were improvements in overall survival
but not really improvements in
progression free survival so immunologic
therapies at least using older
definitions of progression free survival
may not change that short-term natural
history but may Clinic result in a
clinically important Improvement in the
natural history in terms of survival and
the opposite of that would be
anti-angiogenic therapy at least
targeted there but you can see up here
VF trap a vast and sutent all resulted
in improvements in progression free
survival but no improvements in survival
and these drugs are not approved um and
so just because a a a drug delays
progression free Survival by a little
bit doesn't mean that it will improve
survival uh this could be because of
excess toxicity it could be because of
other reasons and I'll explain that in a
minute one of the issues is that we
might be misclassifying progression and
this is taken into account with the new
working group guidelines and this is a
great case to illustrate that so when we
get a bone scan in a patient with
metastatic prostate cancer we often see
a few lesions such as this patient right
here who's got a bone lesion in the
sternum PSA of 200 castration resistant
disease this patient goes on to um
active therapy let's say
abadone and 12 weeks later he comes in
his psa's down to 12 and he has a new
lesion as you can see on his bone scan
right there this patient feels great uh
there's no sense of rib pain uh what to
do about this is this progression is
this flare is this healing well bone
scans really image osteoblast activity
they're an indirect tumor biomarker
osteoblasts heal in the presence of
fractures osteoblasts produce more uh
uptake of the technum in the presence of
healing and so osteoblastic activity can
be both a healing reaction or a FL layer
or a progression and in this case the
patient stayed on the drug and his PSA
still declining 12 weeks later and he
still has just the same single new
lesion and this is a great example of
flare or healing in which in the old
days we might have taken the patient off
at week 12 and he never would have
received the great benefit of some of
these drugs and this patient went on for
several years to remain on
abatan uh flares have been commonly seen
with both enzalutamide and abaton they
are emerging and essentially the
guidelines have now changed for
interpreting bone scans in the face of
these active therapies so instead of
taking a patient off a drug for a single
new lesion or a new lesion scene at that
first assessment flare usually happens
in the first four months and so getting
an additional uh bone scan what's called
a confirmatory bone scan uh is
recommended and if you see additional
new lesions over time beyond that first
assessment at 12 weeks or when whenever
you're getting that initial bone scan
for example eight weeks uh if you
develop progression in the face of uh of
an inial uh bone lesion that becomes
real progression if the if new bone
lesions are not developing over time
that's felt to be flare and of course
you have to put this in the context of
the patient so if you have a PSA going
down that may be more of a sign of bone
scan flare bone turnover markers such as
alfos May uh go down with Flare you may
also see uh soft tissue disease and so
you have to put this in the context of
the patient and their pain and other
biomarkers but generally flare is
defined as new bone lesions or flare or
brightness of existing lesions in the
face of an otherwise clinically
responding
patient some of my thoughts on
progression free survival and this
becomes important with many of the new
drugs that are in Trials right now is
that improvements in progression free
survival may be delayed with certain
immunotherapies that really take a
prolonged time to essentially kick in
and so the benefits of drugs like
immunotherapies May really occur Beyond
when a protocol defines progression and
they may slow the rate of rise or growth
rate of the tumor in a way where
progression free survival just can't
capture that using the current
definitions and there are some modified
definitions of PFS that account for
immunologic radiographic changes
cytotoxic therapies produce a pretty
linear relationship between PFS and Os
so toxic drugs like doot taxel and
cabazitaxel have very similar Hazard
ratio for these end points so if you're
looking and screening a cytotoxic
therapy a progression free survival
Improvement uh is a reasonable surrogate
most likely for overall survival
anti-angiogenic therapies however as I
just showed you really have not shown a
surrogate effect so these drugs like
bmab or vef trap or sunit nib did show
modest Improvement in progression free
survival that was statistically
significant but no benefit in OS and
that could be for a range of reasons
such as toxicity rebound growth during
drug discontinuation cross resistance
with other therapies the fourth category
of hormonal therapies abadone
enzalutamide and other emerging hormonal
agents there should be a strong impact
on PSA and so PSA may be a good
surrogate really needs to be validated
in these phase three trials to see
whether we can use PSA reliably to to
start and stop a patient on these active
hormonal agents and thus the message
here is that the relationship of an
endpoint to survival does depend on the
mechanism what about response so PSA can
go down and patients live longer we
published this in jco 2007 so a 30% or
greater PSA decline is associated with a
better Improvement in survival uh versus
patients who do not obtain a greater
than or equal to 30% decline this has
been probably the the the the highest
degree of surrogacy in the cytotoxic era
um PSA normalization probably a better
prognostic finding but not a great
surrogate is it's not achieved in very
many men you can see that a drop in the
PSA from the hundreds down to the zero
to four range happened in about 15 to
20% of patients with dose of taxel and
if you achieve that you've got a great
survival almost three years but this
didn't happen very often meaning that
it's probably not a great surrogate for
trials what about radiographic response
as you can see here these are uh box
plots for survival uh in the tax 327
trial and you can see really that
patients who have a complete response or
a partial response with dose of taxel
have almost a three-year survival versus
patients who progress right through with
radiographic progression have about a
one-year survival and stable disease is
important 23 months for patients with
stable disease indicating that
radiographic scans doing CAT scans is
helpful particularly in patients with
measurable disease however it's not a
great surrogate because most men with
castration resistant disease do not have
measurable
disease so why would a treatment improve
progression free survival but not
improve survival well this could be a
statistical issue you have a treatment
effect that's very small you don't have
enough survival Events maybe post
progression therapies reduce that event
rate we have certainly enough active
therapies that that's a real possibility
it's also possible that statistical
significance with PFS does not translate
into real clinical significance and thus
no improvement in survival so if you
improve psf PFS by a week and your P
value is highly significant maybe that's
not really all that
important uh treatment related mortality
so what if a drug improves your
progression free survival but it
actually leads to grade five lethal
toxicity in patients uh where that risk
outstrips the benefit and so there
benefits to Su and harm arms to other
that's a real possibility there's also
what I just described to you as
measurement error so if we're
misclassifying progression uh where
actually it's response uh we're going to
get the opposite result and dilute our
effect but also important many of these
drugs promote cross resistance to the
others we've seen a number of reports
showing cross resistance through some
chart reviews of enzalutamide and
abadone and you'll you'll see a number
of emerging trials looking at that
progression um uh rates on uh that are
related to cross resistance and this is
due to altered tumor biology and
adaptive mechanisms that promote cross
resistance through tumor Evolution or
clonal selection that make a a patient
resistant to both of these drugs
including other chemotherapies as well
thus we have a list of many different
mechanisms of drugs and the relationship
of an endpoint such as a surrogate to
survival does depend on the mechanism of
action of the drug under
evaluation so to conclude what's the
Pervert end point in phase two
castration resistant trials response or
progression and I'm not going to answer
that because I don't know yet and I
would just say that it really depends on
the mechanism of your drug as I showed
you the mechanism is critically
important PSA declines may be very
helpful when you're screening a hormonal
drug um bone scan changes as long as
you're using the working group two
progression criteria where flare
reactions are considered are also
important ways to screen uh for
progression free survival for many of
our active agents maybe not
anti-angiogenic drugs though immunologic
therapies uh really don't result in bone
scan responses PSA therapies at least
our first generation immune therapies
and so maybe survival is a more
important endpoint for screening in
phase two trials of immunologic
therapies resist responses are only
useful if you have measurable disease
and typically that's less than 50% of
men particularly in the predosa taxal
setting uh many many have proposed using
reductions in bone biomarkers over time
but again that would only be important
if these biomarkers were elevated at
Baseline and uh finally I just want to
talk about uh progression free survival
as well as circulating tumor cells so
those are also under uh evaluation for
surrogates but right now we just don't
have enough data that's published
linking the circulating tumor cell count
or change uh across multiple trials and
mechanisms as a surrogate and that
hopefully that data will be emerging
over the next year or two so to conclude
and I'm going to start taking questions
in about one or two minutes uh just to
reiterate the prognostic factors
biomarkers inform on natural history and
have a role in treatment decision-making
in terms of whether a patient has
aggressive disease symptomatic disease
visceral disease all these things are
important in our nccn guidelines and in
our labels for example patients with who
are candidates for sipt are generally
painfree without visceral disease while
patients who are canis for radium have
no visceral disease and need to have
symtomatic bone predominant disease and
these are prognostic biomarkers that can
inform on Natural History uh and
treatment selection however predictive
factors are really biomarkers that
inform directly on a specific therapy
current treatment selection algorithms
really do not use uh blood-based
biomarkers to really identify therapies
other than perhap perhaps small cell
prostate cancer which really doesn't
make a lot of PSA in which Platinum
agents are used
commonly but um currently we do not use
molecular biomarkers to guide therapies
and that is likely to be the wave of the
future by interrogating Androgen
receptor biology by looking at AR
independent prostate cancer enogen that
may be important as we develop drugs
that Target these Pathways that is
really the focus of future efforts given
numerous treatment options and finally
surrogate biomarkers they're very
important for getting drugs approved you
have to understand that they these
biomarkers are mechanism and context
dependent you it's very unlikely that a
single biomarker will be a surrogate
across all mechanisms of drugs and you
know for example hormonal drugs a
hormonal biomarker such as PSA readout
may be a reasonable uh surrogate uh
circulating tumor cells may be a
surrogate but needs to be studied across
many different positive trials and and
essentially we need qualif across
multiple trials to address this topic of
surrogacy so in conclusion if we can
take these biomarkers and tailor our
therapies such that perhaps we're
defining Raph mutated prostate cancer
urg overexpressed or ar splice variant
prostate cancer or P10 null prostate
cancer or tubulin mutated prostate
cancer we can tailor our therapies to
these specific individuals who Harbor
these uh perhaps EXP exploitable
mutations and we can get at these
mutations from tumor biopsies from
circulating tumor DNA from circulating
tumor cell uh biomarkers and ideally in
these subgroups we would expect a
greater impact on survival with than
empirically derived therapy so I put
here all the survival benefits that
we've seen in kind of unselected
patients hopefully we can move to a six
or 12 month Improvement in survival with
uh selected populations who are more
likely to benefit
so with that I'd like to thank you and
I'm going to start taking
questions and um all right so I have a
first one from
Victoria uh she says with the discovery
and progression of new drugs what is
being done to preserve the drug in its
original configuration from being made
in a generic form as some of the drugs
you are using are being used in common
comination with other drugs to combat
the cancer and will those drugs be
preserved as well due to the different
fillers and binding properties of the
generic drug that's an important
question you know certainly uh we're
looking at uh some drugs already like
dose taxel going generic and probably at
least 101 15 years before abadone and
zide go generic um certain biologic
agents may never go generic such as
culis LT it's really an autologous
immunotherapy and it's not clear that
that could even be made into a generic
um but I think uh it is important as we
develop biosimilars as generics come in
that uh the pharmacokinetics of these
drugs are studied to make sure that
we're not dealing with greater
variability Patient to Patient uh using
biomarkers to interrogate those trials
as generics are being developed it's
really not enough just to show the same
uh pharmacokinetic I think showing a
similar safety profile uh
showing some similar efficacy is also
important for these generics but I think
it's an important
question so the second question is uh is
this a
means uh to better avoid treatment and
so yeah I would say that I'm not talking
about avoiding treatment here these are
men with really lethal prostate cancer
uh this is uh these are patients who
have a one to three or four
survival um most of these men will
become symptomatic within a year uh if
they're asymptomatic and so it's really
the talk that I gave is really
identifying patients to better sequence
our therapies not necessarily to avoid
treatment entirely now it's possible
that if you have an asymptomatic patient
with minimal disease burden and a very
slowly Progressive disease I think you
could reasonably say we could defer
therapy such as if we were to use tolt
or or a clinical trial of a
immunotherapy for a patient with um low
burden of disease that patient could be
safely observed often for a long period
of time without needing cytotoxic
therapy or hormonal therapy but I think
the talk that I was giving is really
identifying patients who would benefit
the most from our therapies and would
spare society and individuals the cost
and harms of ineffective therapies and
we really need to move towards that as
well
all right here's a question um
from why aren't the studies not focusing
much on drug metabolism given the
reported adverse reactions so I'll just
give you an example of that abadone has
focused greatly on drug metabolism at
least in the drug development of that
there is great patient-to-patient
variability with that drug there's a
high food effect with that and so the
FDA label recommends taking AB ratone
without food taking it with food
actually increases the absorption 3 to
400% and so there are some strategies
looking at um ways to take that drug
with food that maybe would allow you to
use less drug and save fun save
funds uh or to take higher doses to
overcome some of the other enzymes that
abadin might inhibit such as the three
beta hydroxy steroid dehydrogenase
enzyme so but um I think you're right I
think there's a lot to be learned about
even some of our commonly used drugs
like dose of taxal metabolism how
certain patient characteristics such as
obesity hormonal status um
pharmacokinetics interact and a number
of the phase three trials are measuring
these things um I didn't talk about
pharmacokinetics a lot in this talk that
was a little beyond the scope but these
are important biomarkers in drug
selection currently we do not measure
the PKS of any of these active drugs um
which I agree is a problem particularly
if you have drugs that have high
variability Patient to
Patient okay so I think we have
completed our talk I'd like to thank you
for the attendance uh certainly uh this
will be available on the web uh for
uh lab roots and I'd like to thank
you
for
and I'm just highlighting here to obtain
your CME credits There's the link and
for those of you still on the line uh
this is the last slide so um this is the
web page for the biocon live.com CME
link to obtain your CME for this
talk